it's just gonna be easy coming through
it hi I'm Hannah I'm the worlds of chaos
mom and if you didn't notice the
majority of last year I was pregnant and
right before Christmas I had our third
son his name is Henry he's the sweetest
little thing and his birth definitely
taught me that you can plan all you want
and things can completely derail anyway
so here's my birth story on Friday last
Friday the doctor checked to see how
dilated I am which is like how far open
my cervix has gotten so on Friday I was
a 1 which is pretty low not a big deal
but then on Wednesday I was a 3 so my
doctor told me to stop going into the
office um
and work from home so I've been doing
that but nothing has happened I feel
very accomplished that we got a crib and
then in his little bins we're gonna play
go fish I elected to be induced and
first I was over being pregnant I didn't
want to go past 40 weeks to Henry's due
date was very very close to Christmas I
didn't want to take away Christmas from
my other kids I wanted to be able to
enjoy Christmas with them and be home
and not risk being in the hospital on
Christmas one day out from baby time the
boys are at a movie with Matt I'm not
feeling imminent labor really I was kind
of hoping he would come out on his own
but it's just not happening I'm gonna be
induced tomorrow morning at the hospital
we have to get there at 5:00 a.m. I've
had some like pre labor indications
which worrying at really TMI up in here
you lose this thing called your mucus
plug which is like a lining that
protects the baby from infection
like I think it kind of seals off your
cervix and then another sign that labor
is coming is diarrhea never thought I'd
be like excited to get diarrhea but I'm
not gonna lie I was kind of excited
because I was like oh maybe it's
happening but it's just not happening
I'm really not hungry at all anymore
it's like almost 1 o'clock and I still
haven't eaten anything and I'm not
hungry
he's definitely dropped my stomach is
like pretty small it looks flatter and I
lost weight at my last doctor's
appointment which is also a sign that
labor is approaching but yet he is not
coming I definitely wanted to kind of
focus on the kids for that last weekend
so we decided to not do phones or
electronics so we did some baking we did
some you know holiday preparation and
stuff so this is my last meal I have
been craving these spicy Korean rice
cakes and crispy dumplings oh I'm so
excited I am having a baby today
monday came I had to be at the hospital
at 5:00 in the morning so it was pitch
black outside but I wanted to make sure
that I had my hair and makeup done how
lucky was I to be induced and actually
have the luxury of doing my hair and
makeup for labor I'm completely shocked
and I'm having this baby already it's
just very bittersweet not only this is
the end of my last pregnancies the last
day is family for about what time is it
okay we're in the car it was a slow
start and we have to get there by 5:00
a.m. yeah I was a little late but
it's not gonna start without me it's
like a wedding
you know I was late to my own wedding
because it wasn't gonna start without me
it's the same thing for Labor you can't
start it without me so my pregnancy was
very mellow and so I assumed the birth
would be just as easy and I was wrong
I'm headed into the hospital it's
happening we're here
and then my gown they asked me a lot of
questions we have monitors look that's a
contraction monitor the baby heartbeat
monitor and we're gonna say goodbye to
this bump it's 6:00 in the morning now
yes she's like 4 centimeters I feel good
how do you feel I'm nervous but yeah I'm
really nervous what are you nervous for
just because you're gonna be going
through so much
[Music]
the most common way to be induced is
with an IV drip of what's called pitocin
it is synthetic oxytocin which is the
chemical that kick-starts labor so I got
an IV drip of pitocin and put it in the
side of my wrist so I'm getting
contractions probably like four minutes
apart but they're not very strong and
it's just a waiting game it's seven I
love
and we're just waiting for things
Supergrass shopping yeah but they're
getting worse it hurts more and they
turn the pitocin up say like a four out
of ten
but deandra's here she's gonna take
photos why I decided to do my hair and
makeup for Labor was because my friend
Deandra agreed to come photograph the
birth if you've seen other videos she's
popped in a lot of them because she
photographs pretty much every milestone
for my family and she's our good friend
so I was really happy that she was going
to be there to help document this
there's one coming right now yeah
[Music]
everything just feels really tight
that's it sober
that was the contraction welcome thanks
for joining my TED talk trying to get
him to come out I think Matt was
genuinely nervous and so he was doing
all the things that I was supposed to do
to like feel better and calm down with
me you don't have to do this you don't
[Music]
like my speech you're still here nothing
has changed
waiting it hurts more but I have to wait
till 2:30 get my water broken boom the
contractions are starting to hurt more
they're closer together
and I keep burping every time it happens
my mom has been there for all of my
births she's a person who just kind of
knows what to do in any situation she's
another mom so like when hits the fan
she's the person I call but in true mom
fashion what she did was when she found
out Deandra was going to be at the birth
as well she brought all the fixings for
like a full-blown charcuterie board and
set it up in my hospital room and
everybody ate in front of me
jerks eating in front of me yeah
look at these jerks with their delicious
sandwiches you're not supposed to eat
during labor I was very jealous and I
ended up doing something I wasn't
supposed to do but it truly was the best
piece of cake I've ever eaten in my life
hey there's mine coming so as the day
progressed I was having consistent
contractions and they were moderately
painful but I was not dilating at all
and it became very clear that this kid
was not going anywhere until my water
broke she just brought my water this is
not something I had ever experienced
before and it was very weird basically
the doctor has this little hook that
she'll stick up there and like hook the
bag of water and and rip it open
oh there's fluid pouring out every time
I move now I've been having more intense
contractions and
and it hurt I thought that the
contractions were painful before she
broke my water but I did not know pain
until after she broke my water like
everything is twisted up inside of your
body and like ripped apart at once that
and my mom were trying to push pressure
points that supposedly help with the
pain just for those of you who don't
know what an epidural is it's the pain
management that hospitals provide during
labor my original birth plan was to get
to the hospital get hooked up to the
pitocin
I was already 3 centimeters dilated so
labor should not have taken very long
and I wanted to deliver without needing
an epidural none of that happened
my pain is that like a 50 at this point
and I just vividly remember Matt and the
nurse we're having a conversation about
whether or not I should get an epidural
I had waited and waited and waited and
tried so hard to not ask for one and
then I just got hit with this horrible
contraction and so mid contraction I'm
literally like I'm gonna do
yeah really when you're in the thick of
labor there are no words to describe
that kind of pain it is vomit-inducing
pain I'm just tired as I was getting the
epidural I realized there was a very
good chance that it wasn't going to work
because I could feel the baby's head's
descending as I was getting my epidural
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
with each one I kept telling myself this
is the last one you're gonna feel Hana
it's the last one you're gonna feel your
epidural is gonna kick in you're not
gonna feel them anymore and then I'd get
another one and then I'd be like okay
that's the last one we're gonna feel the
epidural will kick in and it will work
and then I feel another one finally
after so many contractions
it's dawned on me that I was about to
feel everything but luckily my doctor
you could hear her little heels clicking
down the hall she was like running and
hurt he home threw on some scrubs and it
was time to push
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
and just like that Henry was here he was
healthy and good they placed him on my
chest I was crying he started crying
they're like wiping them all down and
checking him out while he's on my chest
and and I'm just looking down at my
baby's face and it's like that that's
who was in there all this time and it
was amazing and that's when my epidural
decided to kick in so we stayed in
recovery for 24 hours which is the
minimum you have to stay to make sure
everything's stable with the baby and
then we got out of there and drove home
so the boys could meet their new baby
brother Wyatt c'mere
[Music]
I really wanted to document this and
show what one birth can look like for
somebody but the thing to keep in mind
is it can go so many different ways you
literally never know what's going to
happen all about the common goal of
keeping the baby safe and keeping the
mom safe and keeping everybody healthy
and so birth looks like so many
different things for so many different
people that this is just one tiny tiny
version of what it can look like so
that's all I got for today I'm Hanna and
if you've given birth shout out in the
comments
tell us your birth story and if you have
any reactions or thoughts about mine
leave that in the comments as well now
if you'll please excuse me
this guy's time tie here oh oh Bobby's
got to get to bed
[Music]
you